were so full podcast welcome to the were
so full podcast with Felipe Esparza and
the co-host was the most and toast well
Gina Torres
yeah man was that butter egg from Judah
Taurus man with the voice of steel the
mannerism of mannerisms the Krakatoa of
Krakatoa the volcano of volcanoes
Roderigo Torres
but you hate that we're people you don't
even know give you these long details
about your name that got nothing to do
with you hell yeah
virtual radio station like a no pass
over hey Rodrigo Torres the Terrorizer
the comedian you got joke throat this
morning don't you you guys talking about
I don't know this man I remember doing a
radio station in it's guy was like you
know like he could charge been the
Raider for a long time and he kept
throwing in a restaurant without even
getting permission for a radio station
everything brought Phillippe but you
like margaritas there's a fine play
margaritas that number the margaritas
here promoter show what's up fool let's
get to the upcoming shows we came up we
have all a big show today two big guys
on it me and him this weekend my HBO
special translate this is premiering at
10:00 p.m. we are having the premiere
party here in our lane 50 listeners are
going to be watching it with me 50
listeners next week October 6th and 7th
well 3 go and I and Toby Hicks are going
to Nashville Tennessee October 8th stand
up live in Huntsville Alabama that's
right they're gonna give us a ride
October 12th through the 14
well gee I hope you got your passport
dogs ready hope you're ready dog ready
ready I'll be bringing those edibles
maybe not we'll find something there
October of 12 to the 14 Edmonton Alberta
Canada at the comic strip if you want to
bring some yeah my shirts go ahead and
bring them perfect are they buying merch
over there no no bro you didn't come
home with Canadian dollars the Queen's
October 20th her San Diego at home fries
by the bay
October 21st the next day Reno Nevada a
silver legacy casino I love this casino
I could talk about this casino
all day they know the only reason I like
this casino is because this is the
casino that they filmed that movie
kingpin in we're worried woody harrelson
was taking on Bill Murray and kingpin
mr. McCracken I'm bowling and bowling
and when I went over there the first
time when I opened up for Paul Rodriguez
I really that thought that they had a
baked potato bar fable [ __ ] stupid
dog he never looks so good the guy from
the fat guy from that band
Bruce travelers uh-huh he sings that
song then he goes yeah don't forget to
travel the silver the Silver Lake casino
known for the biggest potato buffet has
potato buffet
oh my god so um but why I did go there
man the silver legacy casino does have
my next door in a casino there's a big
big bowling alley where they have
bowling it saw me there now they come
the door
so my I don't know gonna have time to
get a bowling in there but what's right
and also don't forget don't forget our
kings comedy podcast festival I will be
there October 26 Phoenix Arizona the one
show only October 26 we're gonna do a
live podcast show
Rodrigo 9 we still don't know who's
gonna be the guest but we'll find
somebody check out Felipe's world.com
slash tour for all the show dates the
rest of the year
shout outs ASAP - the channel from
Oxnard Ramiro Cortez who's out there
driving around for work are they a d-19
who's been listening since the second
episode
mr. nervous keep it 100 sugar booger two
four eight eight another truck driver
listener who listens during his
nighttime drives
on his way to pick up hookers dedicated
dedicated mic McMichael phone $0.99 Mike
iPhone $0.99 Oh from Santana Natalie
from Oxnard ours is the first podcast
she ever listened to and her
two-year-old is always listening with
her trying to say what so full ice cups
who says were awesome and in the best
part cars out there I love ice clubs
dolo mike dolo - Mike who started
listening since we started he calls
those Batman and Rodman next podcast
batsman and Rodman's tight I'll be a
good actor I'm a witness on a being a
caller yeah my mother my own superhero
she kind of Batman come on Ruben and
it's gone she kind of Batman and Robin
holy immigration Batman to a bad
apartment like the life also bone bonnie
bo and any who wants us to know that you
don't have to be Latino to love this
podcast she's not or he's not not sure
if it's a woman or man jo ma p --ba toma
Biba v who listens and talked to us on
instagram all the time even 76 who works
overnight in a grocery store and is
always looking for more podcast to
listen to he says George Perez was never
on Rogan then oh he says if George Perez
was never on Rogan then he never would
have listened to George's podcast and
never would have heard me as George's
gasps and never would have listened to
our show hell yes Steven 76 you know
what's up okay there's our other food I
got a redraw past border Kenya poor Vida
rocket pockets the guy who wants
diamonds a glass oh one one eight nine
Nate in our lane treks theology rich by
rod poncho
five six to raid alarm on
Tony Illuminati eight illuminator Club
get right Dean RRR
Carlito's Way I know that fuu-chin goose
chin goose thank you for all your
reviews we were
pitties things I'd like to stop to 100
podcast today because you guys keep it
so let's not slack off let's not slack
off just cool number 70 number 56 right
now and um everybody who's listening for
the first time thank you very much
hopefully you catch up one day we have a
hundred and what a hundred sixty in our
episode how about you have a yeah man
thirty Wow every week to be doing about
30 weeks hasn't been every week it's
been spotty the last month since
everyone's been busy huh yeah man oh you
look like the wolf man your hat and bang
your head little lady took the helmet
off goes like a baby
yeah how it's your part quick when
people show their newborn and their baby
here in law is killer we have a man bun
I know ray babies or the Hillary Kasbah
bro I know baby the bullet-dodger wrong
more [ __ ] over these baby shampoo kill
some head and shoulders
yeah mess a little baby be dusty but
looking like wow I don't know man sup
the babies were the longest black hair
always looks suspect oh hello John
Redcorn baby sorry what can I talk about
bro
hair dye dark oh yeah man what's up fool
man like always people were asking about
you bro ish yeah dude the last time we
seen him was on the way to what Victoria
one of those yeah dude
he hooked it up that sacrum no it's fine
man oh there were some people there who
drove from Victoria to the shore you
serious how far the Victoria from
Houston to our remember we drove
victoria like the it would like man
Victoria guitars every southern huh yeah
dude Victoria's one of those towns kind
of like [ __ ] Corpus Christi still out
there in the sticks man
I couldn't sleep over there so I saw
she's I couldn't sleep
I saw a bunch of documentaries in my
sleep bro I saw one on PBS about the all
the Chicano Movement like Ruben Salazar
Ruben Salazar Cesar Chavez not only that
but there was other ones bro like in San
Antonio they had their own thing going
to except for Cisco they had their own
thing going in cracking and in Chicago
all the serotonergic ah go up north by
portly somewhere and then San Francisco
and now lay bro and they were all one
the rostra kind of movements I know
Mexican American movements but there was
there was no solidarity but there was
like there weren't our own teams didn't
get along there were all different
groups they were just working for San
Antonio shy town and this when I tripped
on I'm like I've been in like a it's
funny like when you find out stuff that
they happen in the past that you had no
idea because nobody teaches you did you
mix in American history but Cesar Chavez
one see they kind of see see back then
he just came by the Navy and he went to
a movie theater and I'm Delano and it
was segregated for other and no
California was segregation you can even
buy a house in certain areas I didn't
know that right yeah dude how
instructions dog so the the way the
movie theater worked was why people
stand in the middle of his theater and
then Mexican sand and black stand aside
I don't even know if blacks were invited
in but there's a Mexican stand aside so
when a food came out of the Navy he was
like a war hero he go there you know
what I'm I paid my due to the country I
could say whatever I want and I for sat
in the middle and nobody took him to
court
there was no lawsuit he didn't get
arrested and then everybody spread the
word yeah man sees he's in the middle so
the next day everybody sat in the middle
with white people and we were all
sitting together and nobody said [ __ ]
yeah so he desegregated the movie
theaters and I was all good
Trippi how that [ __ ] works oh no and
then um - I didn't know that his wife by
Laurie Huerta he's a friend of his mom
showed up with six kids around yeah man
and together him him and her they did
they want they started up protesting the
arm though the migrant workers but it
wasn't about tough protests because you
know migrant work is seasonal so what do
they mean lasts that long you know take
off somewhere else and I didn't know
this man but um at the same time when
they were trying to protest they were
bringing in Mexican from Mexico scabs
scarib wetbacks wetbacks but I stayed
off to mess up their arm their protest
break their Union people don't talk
about that but see that Jerry had no
love for the food it wasn't for those
guys and wasn't for those guys and he
was all about Union for Mexican American
with papers with papers not the one that
are here illegally bro he wanted those
those kind of messing it up yeah but
later it became about them too but I
mean in the beginning it was their
rights too because they were had they
had little dog they was ready to
pesticides on it they had enough people
there no schools there are no bad
schools while the farmer making all that
money and it wasn't took Robert if
Kennedy came in and he was talking to
one of the sheriff needed the votes and
he was asking him going on so so you're
arrested you are arrested these people
without no crimes while we heard it
would be rioting what you heard it
wouldn't be rioting but with any riots
no so you just arrest him under a fake
law and he was telling all kind of bad
why oh why people don't want to hear it
broke some young white people well he
was an attorney general he [ __ ] him he
got him good ruined they know the strike
they helped out
to unify there is a little strike man
but there were some other people man
like from San Antonio and then the the
National Council that Raza was started
we have too many national cousins of
Raza too many other ones but we should
all just be one yeah dude I mean but
everything was different and then back
in the day there wasn't social media so
they couldn't communicate as fast as
they do now dog back then he was sending
telegrams oh so I saw that when um when
I went one of the one of the guys that
was working with Sheila Chavez he wanted
to learn more in his classroom a lot of
chick a lot of mexican-americans they
were not offered the class that the
classes that were offered um in other
neighborhoods that were out of the city
you know like maybe right here where I
live Granada Hills High School they
probably had the more education they
wrote about high school oh yeah like my
high school wrote about it they were we
still had woodshop bro we still had
metal shop like men Oh shop ah
like welding like like if you ask any
parent right now who's forty nine forty
seven thirty eight twenty nine if you
ask him dad if their kids were to come
home and sit down with today we learn
how to weld and we were not using a
pressure cooker you play man you never
take that [ __ ] class you're gonna
burn yourself I was taking these classes
nobody give a [ __ ] oh dude I remember
the guy that uh that was a woodshop
teacher was missing a hand mr. tall but
dude all thoes movements was because
they have Chicano Studies now yeah we
don't I don't even know that so that's
resources for so we're not when that
teacher from from Belmont High School he
organized a walkout man they show the
Latino students getting beat up by the
cops and then in the bottom is the
narrator was saying I'm getting beat up
because they want education II well dude
it's like in Granada Hills they have
chemistry classes over here they don't I
mean
battle the resources but I'll enlarge
the the state of California education
has been [ __ ] put on the back burner
but then like the the ones and they say
urban neighborhoods whatever are even
less funded dog I mean
less fun it sucks dude but I mean it's
because of all those dudes in San
Antonio that got Julian Castro his mom
and all those people they were part of
those like [ __ ] migrant movements and
early political movements you got
involved that's why you have like the
Latino American Lawyers Association out
all those things sprung out from that
[ __ ] yeah that ideal the Latino lawyer
Association the Latino one is huge bro
I've done a lot of fundraisers for them
over the over my my lifetime at the
comedian to get involved
they've always flew me out to I'm
watchin DC and also men um
there's a place called the National
Council at Raza and CLR and I I've done
many shows with him and then LULAC LULAC
is another one Latino you what's God
like you know United whatever it's
called LULAC it's a funny joke but um
it's true story Paul Rodriguez was doing
an interview and he said man LULAC and
national Casa the only time they got
together to work in unity what to get
rid of the pony local dog yeah well
didn't they suppose it one of the
reasons his first show got canceled
because they were complaining there was
too many Hispanics in one house dog yeah
there's a lot of [ __ ] with that I see
that that's not goes to show you man oh
one thing they're good if you want to
get in education but once it's not
getting into a film and telling us how
to represent our own people come on man
you don't need all that [ __ ] we don't
need a place like them to telling us
that there's too many Mexicans in one
television show
so that would so those people are the
ones that got Paul Gigot show off the
air and they complain that Freddie
Prinze wasn't Mexican well that too dog
so a lot of [ __ ] convoluted [ __ ]
but it's League League of United Latin
American citizens League of United
League of United Latin citizen American
citizen American citizen so anybody out
there man listening if you have a kid or
daughter who's not very smart and goes
to school
they recruit kids out of high school to
become lawyers and future politicians of
our United States and they really backed
you up like all right like if I have a
nephew or a niece they want to get into
politics they will really guide your
career like follow your edge
you follow you know to universally and
then one day land you are a job working
for somebody and you get to be a senator
and relax and work for work for 50 years
and never do nothing that's a problem
too many foes up there relaxing but do
you don't even need to do all those
organizations so big that they [ __ ] and
now they have their chosen few I mean
with social media not actually you can
do all that treat yourself now
you know the [ __ ] education starts in
the [ __ ] home anyways do I want to
sound like I'm helping people
oh just by being on the telly mate
you're helping people dog all that [ __ ]
helps even most eating is an order thing
when those fools started getting big and
big they start seeing a lot of Mexican
people that not necessarily [ __ ]
American citizens or Mexican Americans
going a big ass concerts and selling big
ass halls and big-ass Benny's do those
[ __ ] do that are responsible
for all that [ __ ] to dogs it's all
uplift comes in various [ __ ] sources
dog not just buy one for everything you
help all that [ __ ] Paul Rodriguez George
Lopez yeah man was a fool to do last
week man last week what the [ __ ] oh I
had to say a show with flock one them on
Friday he survived he didn't die holy
[ __ ] he's 100 you know that little foo
be making me laugh oh man so I donated
my money bro I don't I am too fat chicks
no too fat chicks I told him most of the
proceeds of last week's show which
wasn't really my money at all because it
was the people the people who pay to get
in for the five sold-out shows their
money which was what it was was supposed
to come to me I donated it like $10,000
to UM the Houston Food Bank and another
$10,000 to the friends for life animal
shelter so this isn't funny right before
we get to the cars and all that I I
never do that by the way I never post
how much money I'm giving away to
charity because none of you got business
you know but this time I did him only
because
was not my money it was nobody like when
I donated its money I have in a bank
already but this money never reached the
bank and never reached me as soon as
they gave it to me I turn it all over to
the charity so I posted it up bro you
would think that I would get like and I
said you would think that will get
positive stuff like gradual ations
flippy doing a good job no bro I said
let him I got nothing but negative it
was like a bunch of losers saying how
about Mexico don't you care about Puerto
Rico aren't you Mexican well you care
about Houston for sticking to the
state's first and then and I and I had
to write listen I am now Red Cross
[ __ ] what are you how did you
give a penny
did you give 10 cents know one of them
hold on oh well gee I want you to tell
me right now no except for what does a
meme that says I support anything how
much money that give anybody nothing
okay thank you see the people thing just
by reporting I support daca you're gonna
be an angel [ __ ]
a man you know what man a person that
gives a dollar every month to charity
it's more [ __ ] an angel than you'll
ever be [ __ ] and reposted a meme
yeah I was tell my dad that I felt bad
everything happened in Mexico feel bad
or if you're gonna do if you're not
gonna go over there and start moving
rocks and shut the [ __ ] up damn yeah bro
I won't think about family there dog
what happened dude he said it was [ __ ]
up cuz two weeks before that the Hat I
shouldn't chap on his five hundred miles
away
but this fool is in um the two fools
that live there they're pretty modern
buildings so nothing happened but he
said it was [ __ ] you can feel that
[ __ ] jump but they got homies they have
seven homies that they lost their
buildings where they're at so they were
at school so they weren't in there when
that [ __ ] went down and two of the other
people were at work but a [ __ ] [ __ ]
got demolished it so they're spending a
night I want one of my cousin's house in
the other fool has two friends over
there at their pad man it's it's it's
crazy dude but he's off it surprisingly
how everybody came together but the
other [ __ ] he said is a bunch of scams
dog and other [ __ ] dressing up
like the government jacking people dog
but social media has helped out with
that but still there's a lot of [ __ ]
going on let's go over algae go even
here in America a lot people probably
see that they're gonna take care of
somebody's house in Houston and
don't buddy stick out with the money odd
and these people coming off
nationalities matches white because they
are white people of the robbing poor
redneck people oh and there's Mexicans
out there robbing poor immigrants
and there's african-americans robbing
important Americans it just be smart man
you know man if you need help research
everything bro don't just take the first
help that comes to you man you know you
ask around you know your body just like
our body man when you have a body and
the doctor says well you're gonna need
this now and he's gonna cost this much
if that was your car you would have said
that's too much i'ma what to another
mechanic you could do the same thing
with a [ __ ] doctor yeah yeah you're
you gonna treat your body like it's your
car man if this doctor says you need
this [ __ ] their doctor go to another
doctor second opinion man yeah you need
your leg up into the [ __ ] that man
I want to keep my tie you walking around
like two minutes say I know man
yeah marry some happy meals over here
yeah man scammers dude that come in all
shapes and sizes dude that's just human
nature to be bad or good there's camera
and an e phone means who are robbing
people and I was talking to Raymond from
the Houston improv okay he told me
straight up man that dog those houses
they had like we're on two feet of water
already like the towns that were right
next to the levy he goes the the city
had to make a decision well this house
already destroyed so they had to release
the water so they release the water so
the whole thing won't come out and
destroy the whole city so they start
releasing water little by little and
that's how most of those places in the
know ten feet deep of water so in order
to say the whole city they had to
sacrifice a little bit sacrifice the
houses are we gonna [ __ ] up yeah cuz
that dudes in a real estate business
right he knows what's up with all that
stuff
[ __ ] we'll [ __ ] up bro you know we
know we're finding we're driving in the
waters dry but okay you know what
they're where we are on Katie Road okay
you know you know that turn that you
makes you go to the improv uh-huh that's
[ __ ] with all covered up really dog oh
you can't even see that freeway but you
can see the top only
the bottom one it was done bro wait till
you see those sign they're saying but
somebody IKEA writer they're gone
water series gone bro it was all [ __ ]
flooded dude and um there was no way to
bring in food there was no caught way
through cars to get in they had a curfew
at midnight you can't be walking around
the city
straight up damn dude it was bad brother
Cubans washing up in Houston bro back on
your town formal talk oh he may wound up
to torment us tremenda my homie sobre
Neto yo ego pariah la posada that's not
too nuts bro and um he I was talking to
Tommy and he said that um no man
everything went to a standstill like he
said that he was trying to call people
up and they were not even picking up the
phone or no ring dial but I see how the
water dry up drug business went back to
normal because because there was a it
was like a lake between these people you
know I want to know what a [ __ ] water
cool that's what I'm saying
they pump it all out to dry out do they
make [ __ ] like wood cutouts or
whatever drainage spots yeah man so
people people just people are always
gonna be that happy huh like even if I
were to put this money let's go to
Mexico and Puerto Rico somebody would
roll how about Houston don't we live in
America nobody they were gonna be happy
dude there's always gonna be a bad seed
in a box dude always did
that sucks of people haven't even have
to say [ __ ] and I don't know it's funny
cuz it's you though but it's like dude
man people have no chill ha full and
then another one um Lisa posted a post
of us together on her page then some
Latina girl shows up and goes
Mexican Oh a merry-making white chicks
oh we couldn't make it
you've been with Lisa for 10 years who
were you [ __ ] 9 years ago well you're
welcome
where are you right home what do you
look like a dude who cares though dude I
mean dude I mean give me a break dude if
you weren't all I'd do anything like
would even on the radar where they'd
even be mentioning in come on waiting on
your
for the plumber in paint any money into
your happiness dude were so for though
the earthquake brought our motto that's
what I'm saying I'm over here kicking
over these two Mexicans I missed my
flight cuz I smoked those Louis weight
joints and he gave me two more he's our
dam this philanthropy was Wade over here
I was all happy
he was great though dog that was tight
yeah but yeah dude it's [ __ ] great
guys great episode dog it was awesome
hell yeah from beginning to end up
they're all great dog I didn't let press
over there man you've been [ __ ]
working always press on non-stop working
abroad I got my lies down now
well how many spots you been doing like
four or five a day dude plus phone I'll
hold you're probably right
oh my god yeah oh you've been on fire
since when Adam Murray was gonna be here
man it's funny when you when you do an
interview with a fan you know there was
like a selfie book the whole Interphone
a feeling I know you're somebody you
want to document it and their little
picture with celebs check this out man
what's up I went to the Houston Astros
game and his [ __ ] cholo Wow
every time I see how hard Mexican always
the cholo walking in with a big-ass pit
bull at the one a damn Queen has do
inside the stadium yeah stop it you're a
star
where you go with that dog that's what's
around me because it's a service dog
service dog who the [ __ ] service this
[ __ ] where's the canteen
sergeant the Marines in the service a
service dog what is wrong with you sir
nothing I didn't get in there yeah the
laws are beautiful nobody stopped them
I'm talking about
he was hold on oh right so with that for
way more than chapel there's a mean as
pit bulls out there I saw bamboo brother
those big an errand on her blue eyes -
ah dude that's [ __ ] nuts - nuts man
was that game dude oh man who buy the
best day time out there dawg are you
serious was 90 degrees 98 with related
to a side uh-huh
as soon as you get like
within within walking distance to the to
the stadium you can feel that cold air
hitting you're so darn close I would in
there do it AC cuz at nighttime too cuz
they're the original Astrodome is closed
that's a new one right yeah - so it's
all modern in there and perfect cuz that
Ranger Stadium was pretty modern - dog
yeah man it's modern and fool we got to
hang out with Josh Reddick now that for
the Dodgers yeah
Dodgers waifu could they trading him oh
he liked that lazy him bad he said they
did him dirty like Eric Karros well he
kind of sloped in the beginning but then
in the playoff he were been in 289 so a
winner so uh we got to really hang out
with mr burger oh yeah really hang out
with him right
so the next day type who would over for
you can't go to improv anymore mr.
Riddick start up to Josh Reddick and I'm
here the home wait
yeah bro my my boy rubble him bro is its
assistant breath boys grew up with
everybody hard enough with the boys bro
what are you gonna do something dog what
is somebody gonna say my boy Chris your
mom likes me Brown right [ __ ] your pit
bulls battering him winds gonna take
that little food that's where he wears
all clothes dog no bro bone every the
Barbie clothes oh he's so tiny boy and
diverticulitis brow it'll get you Brad
I'll bring those big brother my brother
way to know my bro [ __ ] deal come now
with the tightest shirt and bowtie he
still wearing it from the other years
where he was like 20 pounds lighter
rounds he was wearing that cardigan you
were watching a football game and
everybody was taking a knee
over him he got out the couch and was
taking me by the television dog in
solidarity with his brothers so people
are taking me too far man I know like
somebody somebody did the need during a
concert if it's a concert it's not a
really doesn't mean mean mean Shelly
you're just stopping a [ __ ] showing
showing me the real need Rodrigo Torres
right the real me manly when you're at
when your girlfriend ask your you cheat
on me
then you take a knee no we're gonna pass
you're the only one for me what's up
full pot with our guests right I guess
right here man I vote an honorable guest
yeah we've all we've all voted for him
all of them this guy right here man our
next guest man he was the first Latino
we've seen in a cool movie since [ __ ]
[Laughter]
somebody doing it right been a cool guy
in the movies is this guy saying meat
glue and blood in blood out
oh yeah Michael Gomez and now The Big
Lebowski leads yeah they kind of working
in shifts
yeah yeah man ran into him at all
audition radiation bro yeah you guys do
a little video and she a little selfish
it was time yeah metal time is it it is
12:43 yeah man so with no further ado no
further ado all the way from Oak Street
you know what time it is all the way
from Trinity from West Side the West I
proba Olympic auditorium oh wow bye [ __ ]
the LA of Los Angeles
he knows don't be here really forever
home
we're so fool let's get building
numerous movies play more famous for
nacho libre
that's a guest star right there
the house natural a little kid with a
little chubby kid boy your sweat John
John we're so full we have afraid right
here from Efrain right if we're
different
I'm white and crying Antonio Ramirez
come on if I'm from Napoleon Dynamite
was so fool you look the same after the
haircut ha
hold on I got taken me for that he's
taking me ladies gentlemen that's a real
need right there laughter the was so
full only that bro [ __ ] my
cousin are you seeing lated jr. your mom
go yeah Chuy my mom mom my cousin Selena
Selena I grew up with her since she was
a little kid I know her mom Patricia she
was the first woman that took me to a
movie theaters she took my see jaws I
would sit next to her my own fight my
cousin louder and then she'll be over
there making out with a boyfriend
watching a [ __ ] carry-on scared so I
was at my cousin Shalini in the West
Side to the live over there on on
[ __ ] Washington in a big house and
they ran out rooms to buy stuff their
pictures is food cake he was born a star
you know
vote for Pedro cuz you know me Philippe
inspires that cause people buy the
character starts keeper anyway so his
picture was right there he goes yeah man
he's a cousin of ours you know really
Wow didn't know that another cousin in
the business oh really - yeah - buddy MP
feelin all right
mom you know are you sure it's a blood
in blood out so but you grew up in East
LA right
it's a Seaway yeah right stop ohyes
worry yeah 13:43 Concord Street oh my
god by the freeway dog yeah
I'm concur first fear elementary school
the and did so man so you are related to
me but who's your mom who your daddy is
he rich like me no well I know my mom my
daddy got three of them and your dad oh
three babies mamas no my mom is Martha
Martita and my dad's Julio so and and my
mom's cousin is Tia Tania and I think
that's how they were related because we
got cousins and I think we're second
cousins
your cousin named Nancy I do and Wendy
yes yes yes yes I love Nancy the atonia
so your mom is related to media gotta
yeah I had no idea I can and I know the
first there from to spawn I read damn
you're that lady you're talking about
that my mom's first cousin which makes
of third cousin Wyatt yeah Mattia tanya
is my father's first cousin because my
grandmother and I'm getting goosebumps
by the way just in case there are you
listening my grandmother who was she
Lucia Soto is a sister too it's um a
sister to media Tanya's mother which is
Mattia gotta and they all grew up in
cooks Panera and wisdom and me Tia Tanya
she had another son who passed away and
they would Andy the weather you know
every meal and II know he's a crazy
[ __ ] dog he was half white half
Mexican you the original amigo small
goddamn world yes oh man family reunion
up in here oh yeah bro with a family
just a funny story man we're at Salinas
house when were little kids they were
living on
Trinity before they moved to that house
and we were having a barbecue Brody's
booking BBQ was last all [ __ ] day dog
it'll be for cell phones but you have to
make up games
ITL florida bro will put a mighty
Florida and her man don't Miguel they
went they have like a pitch and a
feeling full of Lord and then that they
sizzling brought full of Lord then let's
start throwing pork in there to cook it
dog so we meet our owners are they some
Irish my breasts are like quit like they
were all they were all white like what
eat those bro like you never lets you
had a cheat I look like a pork bone it
comes out of that class oh I'm telling
it's the best stuff on earth I don't
even if you're vegan it's like a piece
of fat where's three lines of meat oh
yeah you put it in the fat it comes out
trunky you put in a corn tortilla with
green sauce forget a lot it stopped so
we were hungry so we'll eat that all day
plus there's also carnitas being
commanders shredding it they're making
them whatever so my mom she puts her
hand to lean on the [ __ ] gate right
just to lean right so grab a little bird
the dogs next door the door benchers not
her hand right away nah her off her hand
like her fingers start bleeding she's
[ __ ] crying everybody the birthday
party freaking out my [ __ ] an is
still moving the [ __ ] fool oh yeah
DJ's keep a beat so rushed to the
hospital dogs and they give her a bunch
of stitches and then I wait then I was
there in the hospital my brother and I
are trying to hit the [ __ ] dog with
Ross from the other side borrowing it
broke the neighbors came [ __ ] your your
dog [ __ ] how are you
hello said one one with finger things
and stitches all over the place like a
dog was hungry how full it snow falling
clover for my dad father give a little
break Mexican man or that man of that
generation don't give a [ __ ] those fools
don't cook and clean dog they watch well
your father like that
did he could be clean no he I mean yeah
he was he he was but my father was a
mechanic so you know and I grew up with
the four brothers so he just taught us
how to build and take apart cars so I'm
work on engines yeah it was a technician
a technician you know that your daddy's
Duma kept let me kind of work under your
skateboard forever
ah dude they don't come out for nothing
huh they send them a sandwich awful how
about eliminating is it miss island and
I don't think that go darling cheese on
a skateboard at that so you get into
acting bro what happened
it's a story here cellblock see I was
talking to this one guy named William so
uh growing up in Boyle Heights things
got pretty bad so we moved to Lincoln
Heights was about like ten minutes away
and and there was blossom vanassa there
and which is a park and they had a
recreational facility that that allowed
kids in the neighborhood to do theater
so my mom put my brothers and me into
theater we started to do plays there and
even my elementary school which was
really cool but slowly I started to get
into acting and I liked it and it gave
me something to do and when I went to
college it would it cost it la I started
to really study theater and do acting
but I really want to get into the
business
sorry went to different acne schools in
the Hollywood and in Santa Monica and
and out in the valley and I took the bus
bike two hours three hours just to go to
auditions just to go just to get in
school like a big nerd so but that but
slowly I said to work as an actor from
doing commercials into small parts and
TV shows and theater and and two feature
films so it did you know one when
Napoleon Dynamite came into my life I
was my life completely changed
after that when it took once it took off
yeah your audition for it yeah yeah I
had I was working on two TV shows at the
time weren't called Boston Public and
another one called even Stevens
you know what that mucosal shia labeouf
so and i end up getting a two feature
film auditions once more one was the
Alamo and then Napoleon Dynamite and I
got both films and I and I and I I asked
my dad like what do I do because one was
a big movie and the other one was a
small independent picture my dad said
well you know just gave me home follow
your heart you know and said yes to
Pedro for her you know like all right
cool so I did that and and and
everything changed and what's up with
that character to the character it but
you know the director had done a short
film called palooka and there were two
characters by name of Gael and Pedro
Gayle spoke English and Pedro only spoke
Spanish so he said watch this and I want
you put these two characters together
and make your character so and I used to
be I have a girlfriend who had three
dogs and one dog had been hit three
times by uh by cars because he lived on
a major street so he was a little slow
and I thought okay they put my they put
my cousin and and Buster Keaton and this
dog together and create Pedro and I
didn't know cuz I thought I was gonna be
fired cousin getting you notes and when
I met John heater as Napoleon because he
was in his closing his costume I think
he's like hey you've heard yeah like
alright cool
this might we just might work yeah so
how'd you do it though of the boys well
I started talking like this and I wasn't
so sure or something and you know I
remember him to go to Fox Studios
I didn't know what to do and I remember
when I when I when I was gonna go meet
the director and producers the first
thing I did was I went into my father's
closet and I took his clothes that's
what it was yeah I put on his clothes
and and I went in there i fox videos and
I'm like sitting ban in there and like
talking like that I'm thinking okay
maybe this is gonna work so you know you
you kind of make your choices as an
actor and next you know I get a phone
call and my manager my agent say you
know you you got the you know the film
for the Alamo you got the film for the
point I might you know what do you want
to do and so I chose Napoleon Dynamite
love that would have been a smaller role
huh yeah yeah but you when you're
working on a studio picture because of
such a huge cast with Dennis Quaid and
Billy Bob Thornton you know you're under
contract for like I don't nearly two
months I thought cool smaller role but
for two months great you know in Texas
why not
but because Napoleon Dynamite was such a
it was a lead role you know and it was a
character role I wanted to take that
role you know and I I was afraid at the
time because you know you I didn't know
what was gonna happen with my life my
career and whatever you know so so but I
took that risk and it was that risk that
that made me who I am today
I always tell your voice on it that
because it's authentic because you know
like when they do it like you know they
want to make it more Mexican whatever
and it sounds like too exaggerated yeah
that sounds like a dude that's a dude
that you know you've seen before or
whatever yeah all I doesn't want to do
the wrong things I want straight and
narrow that we shot him Idaho we shut
that and again Preston Idaho you know
and it's funny because I actually have a
really milked those cows sounds care
they milk me what no I saw it with my by
myself on a date and with my son dude
it's like the characters and everything
cuz I'm from Riverside dude there's yeah
white people just like that no
nachos and [ __ ] man the worst is when
I'm gonna pull in dynamite is they feed
them that [ __ ] horrible orange ooh
with eggs father
that's jumbo G before Jamba Juice put
orange juice and those [ __ ] blender
and him put two eggs in April and blend
that [ __ ] and give us each was
oh my god what did you fry the egg give
me orange juice kill you makes you
stronger
well you did the movie man yeah okay my
know you can't say but at least tell it
one celebrity you had with I know man
you know you know peace how everybody
was okay Lopez no he got some oh they
know the dude man but that would just
quit Alfred Oh Jane Hernandez crazy
beautiful lives about five minutes away
from me okay it's cool we start with the
plane yeah go to Chicago no yeah yeah
yeah no that guy uh a little banner
people that night maybe but maybe if I
hang around Ephraim I get another movie
to recharge my career I've never seen
Mario at the at the Playboy Mansion
yeah well if I'd have been uncle Hef
he's buff ha a little party when you
went to the Playboy Mansion but they're
actually an event well they're a charity
event or with a real real party it was a
that was a [ __ ] charity event bro
there was there were people there you
don't want to see naked man that's a
charity when you went to the goal like I
was doing you a few of the events and
one of them I think well my favorite one
was the Halloween parties
but it's it's yeah they have your number
that time so I invited all of you guys
till here in this room what happened so
okay so I was there and I got a seat
first of all um I don't know if you guys
know this or not but I do have a twin
brother right Marshall right
so yeah this is Carlos and and and uh
yeah you google that and but my twin
brother dressed up as a kissing booth
right so an i is rule yeah genius he had
a whole box around him and you know and
there was some part of money in and I I
come open Nick who I end up dressing up
like the crow right yeah I'm like God
working now going on I'm gonna go ask
Roku yeah like all right you know so but
my page might my face is all painted so
we show up and all the girls are like
looking at my brother going oh my
goodness Pedro they're all kissing oh
he's got a kissing booth and and I'm
like you know oh nobody wants it like
beer on me cuz I got a you know painted
face who are you and like I'm just a
writer I guess I don't have a twin
brother but I have fat gay little Amy
seven bad browsers out there seven bad
Bronstein we know a guy named Rick
Gutierrez who like who like Charles
Bronson he got hit in the head with 7
bats
you should call too bad Bronson who bad
Rock do shows up bro I put on my
Instagram he's just a chubby little guy
with curly hair bro
buys a t-shirt and then I'm somebody
before the show and a Philippe That's
not me
then the security guard listen bro you
just say it's you
another genius maybe right
so this fool by the shirt before the
show starts puts it on and he's but he's
hanging around by the other side broke
people dog those are guys there who own
a strip bar oh he own rich strip bar
shoutout to the owner of Ritz in Houston
that fook gave me a number and it was
call me I let everybody know you're
coming
anybody showed up with with strippers
brought that were like the third that
they were at the d-string
last time they played was a no.9 they
were stripping a super boat and row miss
quad like I'm a very one of them like
even a short one like she do like she
was like Heather Graham and actually
more like Heather grandma you know
female gremlin so I always think that
but then think about the owner wouldn't
show up with the pretty ones they're
working they're making money making that
he's where he was d-squad and there are
sisters so this fool is because
Burroughs broke oh crap that chick dog
over there and the girls grab his face
and motorboats on bromine he's walking
around like Felipa stubble grabbing
everybody but he may go you don't strip
no more bush they were all strippers at
one time they were all so had a ball huh
and then with him so what's up fool so
you did the movie yeah and I saw um the
actor uncle Rico was his name-o Johnson
Grice yeah and he was you you were in a
band with him right yeah why harmonica
he's uh in between working and
a lot of actors and and a lot of actors
are actually either band members or
they're DJ's so and and because I played
I played harmonica for years a lot of
bands will ask if I could go up on stage
with them and play it and play my
harmonica which is cool
I've actually performed over at the
Greek Theatre with a bunch of other
actors and you know I it was great yeah
you can't go up there in front of
thousands of people you're like wow this
is cool
yeah it's fine so Hollywood playing
harmonica how'd you get into that uh I
think my mom my mom had gone down to
Mexico and then she came back she gave
me a harmonica and when I was in high
school and I was I don't know I was
really the quiet kid who sat in the back
you know and I could just just you know
the big nerd
so uh and I and I would play my
harmonica you know during lunch time and
I think there was a moment when I would
take the bus and and I'd be waiting for
the bus and I just play my harmonica
because you can't walk around with the
piano right no so that was that and I
said to play my harp and and three years
uh my neighbor was from the south and he
taught me how to play a harmonica and he
introduced me to different kind of music
from you know from Chicago blues to
southern blues to straight Harv across
art and and since then I've just been
playing you got some harmonica right now
I don't I like a little cherub I would
have brought one if I would have known I
know you're a DJ though right yeah yeah
yeah put things in for a while huh my
older brothers used to be DJs
all over Lincoln Heights and and and
Boyle Heights so and and I'd be like a
you know the little kid carrying crates
of records you know and then just all
old-school stuff so and I remember
having to mix uh like like Al Cool J or
right along with with Depeche Mode well
it was like you don't do that you don't
mix hip hop with new wave and I'm like
ah why not yeah you can't you can't you
can't cross Janet Jackson with uh with
the Cure don't do that no like what so
so uh and part of it is even before
Napoleon Dynamite I should do a lot of
raves in less
Angeles I knew Pasquale and Reza who the
guys who do a EDC and they taught my
friends and me how to do events and the
idea was to create electro music
electronic music and mix that with with
techno and new wave and create something
new but so downtown Los Angeles it was a
club called the Orion and my friends and
I would do all these raves and we were
it was great because we started having
her like I don't know ten thousand
people and grew to about 25,000 people
and it was just getting bigger but that
very moment that's when I in a booking
Napoleon Dynamite's it was a choice to
either do raves in you know or work as
an actor and so I chose the latter
nonetheless you know a lot of around
that time a lot of celebrities will make
appearances at clubs and just like just
say hi to people and I thought I mean I
could do that but I loved DJing I loved
being able to go on the decks and and
mixing different genre music and let
people feel that vibe and it became
where I became a celebrity DJ and I
started to DJ all over the world
and it was just so remarkable because
there's there's some places where it's
all hip hop but they want old school or
they want top 40 or they want the
underground electro dutch house you know
and it's it's it's just great because it
becomes about the music and not about me
yeah man
man when you made that grow that cake in
movies kick and pies to those two
shoulders and then we were there for
Molly
yeah actually from Logan Utah which is
about like 20 minutes south on the
borders of of Idaho and Utah then they
were actively I've never acted before at
all and then actually you know the
director and and one of the Senate
ographers we were actually shopping down
at Kmart and Logan and and they're just
getting more wardrobe for us because it
was such a low budget project dude
yeah they're moments when I headed by my
own lunch or I bought lunch for everyone
yes so it was down that yeah don't need
oh don't eat that you the set food
because we got to eat that later so um
and they saw those guys you just walk up
just shopping and they're like hey you
think those guys can play the yeah Peter
of cousins and then you know the
approach them they said yeah cool homes
so and and that's how the end of getting
into the [ __ ] famous and tore
up summer Wheatly homes that actually
beat that car belong to some other
homies down in Logan who didn't get
along with the actual homies feel like
rivals but it was cool because they're
in the movie that's crazy man
I go to Utah a lot but I'm here a little
I go to a WOM where do we go Salt Lake
with a Salt Lake City and we go to West
Valley never belly West Valley and
solidly see the riddance to each other
lots of mornings over there's a
president put up some more in that movie
the directors are from a Utah right from
Utah Mormon and and they write from in a
small town Preston Idaho but the I went
to BYU you know yeah bring them young
bring them yet wait so uh that's that's
that's where they're from and they
actually I mean they did the short film
they did it for 700 bucks and entered
the still and dance Film Festival they
won the Audience Award and then they
wrote the feature film and when everyone
all the studios read the script they're
like what is this and and nobody wanted
to rep them and because of that they
they raised the money themselves and did
the film and it was at the time when
digital wasn't up to par to where it is
now so everything was shot on film so we
would rehearse and rehearse and rehearse
and go alright we have one take okay we
gotta move on so we really had to oh the
budget of the movie yeah cheese I got
less than that the budget for it was Jon
Heder
what the name of the director Jared Hess
Shari had with his movie like a
big-budget know that I mean did a
million right yeah it was about a four
hundred four hundred thousand dollars
Wow it made over 45 million and three
nice merchandise alone was over 300
million yeah yeah you're in a cartoon
also we did the cartoon uh yeah we just
watch that [ __ ] yeah the cartoon was I
mean it was great it was being able to
the fact that the studio's wanted to to
have us together all together and do the
animated series okay sure
I mean it's something that that it has a
cult following when I do comic-con every
once in a while I see John and and it's
amazing she last time I did that I was
in Toronto and I saw this kid who was
dressed up as hell raiser it's like
seven years old you know with all these
you know pins on his face and everything
he was like like whatever you wanted
it's an awesome feeling to be able to be
a part of a cult classic
Coke Classic where the movie actually
made money
oh yeah there's some movies out there
who are coke glasses do they make
nothing like half-baked we had we had
the guy for that movie over here there I
mean nothing after that movie aired
nobody won't talk to him oh my god so
what you got going next
uh what it's after Napoleon Dynamite
it's been uh like I said everything
changed so I'll do about two projects a
year um and I read a lot of scripts you
know and I like really playing different
things I got I got to say after that I
had done a film called crank with the
Jason Statham and I played a
transvestite and get this I got to my
agent got a whole bunch of letters from
different religious organizations saying
how dare play a transvestite you know
when you know a pedra was such a honored
character I'm like well I'm an actor
right let's give him a little needle
nobody's happy you can't satisfy
everyone yeah Jesus Christ I have a film
in called varsity Punk's it's actually
airing in New York right now and it just
won the the audience award and then I
have a film that's produced by Terrence
Malick heavy drama that comes out this
month and I and I a film I produced with
Blum House is actually in in Spain at
their Film Festival so I'm going
unlimited Spain London and Moscow I'll
be in Russia dude so so and I just
finished coming back from Canada working
on the show but my brain is always new
working on different worlds and
different scripts development deal for
your own show on television yet uh I
never thought of that I just I I mean
why not I mean they gave me one yeah I I
think it's because I've been working on
so many different other projects and
when I work in characters you know I
really try making every character I'd
play unique and different and a lot of
characters that I play tend to come back
and many shows so but I said to really
think like I mean I started to I work as
an actor and I worked as a producer but
I never thought well what if I wanted to
show what or film what would I want to
create and it was only to not like this
year to go oh wait I want to do this now
and approaching different Studios
because as a producer I start to think
about what how far can I go how far can
I take in and because there's so many
there's so many revenues and so many
outlets in regards to different media to
create your own content I want to create
something that's so grand and suddenly
they'll stand out that there are P to to
all audiences
so yeah I'm your character stood out and
I'm Napoleon Dynamite but also when my
wife and I want to show we noted that
the movie carries like a tone to the
whole movie like everybody speaks the
same kind of tone you know it's like
almost like a like it's a play but like
the whatever the
the director you could just see it in
everybody the way they talk nobody
really loud crazy everybody calm I
didn't know what it feels like
everyone's really high he went on the
bowling he's slow his girlfriend slow
they won't the one you asked to dance
and then even everybody chill tempo
he'll talk to a Snoop Dogg he was like
hell yeah
Pedro you know I uh every time I watch
their movies I get hat like nephew so
it's again it's the tone of the writing
in this story and then actually was sick
when I went to Preston Idaho a lot of
people who were and still are like that
you know uh one of the characters I
really find interesting is Lyle do you
remember Lyle he's the one who uh
yeah-hoo-hoo weds him at the end the
bully go right no no he the guy who who
can't talk like this you know I'm about
the arrowheads oh dude that guy sticks
out to the other time over there with
that real guy yes that's him yes okay
that's the only one except they got a
weird it because he's like talking to
himself well they're evil horrible
sandwiches it's like the movie to just
go to him and eating a sandwich just I
have found an arrowhead over there
there's men like him in Maryland he he
actually got there's a factor either
right now and he I got a he checkbook he
spot death several times you know when
he was on a tractor and something
happened I don't know he end up falling
off and the tractor went over him I was
like that scene in Footloose yeah this
one really crashed straight and he he
end up cutting his face and he was
holding his face as he was bleeding rent
into his house and with his wife and
they took him to the emergency room
state yeah so that guy you know he
survived death man before I like his Rex
kwon-do dog Rex quando diedrich bader
who's got a new show on
family home some people that's right
another brilliant character actor it's
bad yeah he's bad an office-based so um
do you direct him every type of
directing or writing your own movie uh
no I'm writing now I'm writing two
feature films and then I but I'm always
reading scripts I'm traveling a lot and
whether I'm DJing or doing charity
events or working on projects you know
it's tough because you're you're I'm
very committed you know but there's also
the other part of there's there's a life
of an actor of having to create the
project and be a part of projects but
then there's a the humanitarian part
which is really get involved with
communities and and and everything
that's going on with the world which is
because right now that thing's pretty
crazy
so in between I I talked to colleges I
go to college and I talk to students or
I go to high schools and talk to
students and I think that's something
that that's look I remember being you
know from Lincoln Heights you know and
people would go we'll go to my school
and talk about you could do just
positive messages and I'm thinking you
know what if I can do that too then hell
yeah dude it's it's just been a trip to
being able to be in that position now
[Laughter]
more to a hamburger joint having a good
hamburger so your mother where's she
from
yeah I got my family studs divided to my
mom she literally had she's about about
12 brothers and sisters so you know and
and and then siloed everything had been
so chaotic in the 60s and in the 80s
because of all the revolution on them
getting a dose and all that and she
mention that one of the one of my uncles
is as a rebel I'm thinking she goes so
if you go down there you might either
get kidnapped a shot and I'm like wow
all right
you know and I got pretty much make oh
you know um they're fit so so when the
earthquake happened I was like ah all
right I hope they're okay so ever thank
God everybody
everyone's cool but you know when you
mentioned earlier about the families
getting together nautical me that now
because I remember that you know you
know and I would have a lot of Thea's
and dealers a lot of uncle aunts and
uncles and I would hear so many
different accents and dialects and I
wouldn't know that they better or Chucho
or do I say spit at the way open up the
house you know there's some ways
different accents I was like I didn't
know
now as an actor to get uh you know
getting older and playing these
different roles you could play some we
didn't character now I'm like wow
alright cool so yeah hell yeah yeah so
did your brother get into acting too we
did we did like I said we did a lot of
theater you know but once uh once I
graduated high school my brother my twin
brother end up going to the military
joined the Air Force for about eight
years then I had a little brother who
was in the Army for about four years and
then after Napoleon Dynamite they both
wanted to get into acting you know but
you you we all know he said you'd you
you can't just just get in it jump on
the boat right you gotta you gotta you
know school yourself hood people get
into comedy too man I think it's that
overnight success when do I get paid
never buck why not starting at 45 and I
tell you making every 65 write your
jokes and give to me another one would
you tell a young guy that wants to get
into acting like a young kid theater
school
yeah like 80 almost told me I was doing
a film ah yeah yeah I remember doing a
film with Paul Rodriguez and it was an
independent filming and he was like I'll
just uh you know like three bucks over
you know and there was a heady almost
like you know the Latin Godfather can I
can I just make a phone call and see
what happens it so you know and so he's
like yeah go down go say hi to him like
all right cool and I'm like he's in a
trailer and not
door door opens the gracefully and I'm
like mr. mr. almost yeah yeah well what
is your name and I'm like uh my my name
is Ephraim IRA's and I'm working on a
movie with Paul Rodriguez and he plays
my dad and are you going to school yes
you could've called yes so I mean he
told me stay in school educate yourself
read a lot do plays do theater come on
this is what you want to do then do it
and I and when with that yes and then
years later after Napoleon Dynamite did
a film called walk out they eat director
with with with with Alexa Vega and
Michael Pena goggle yes right that's
right and and and I saw and I'm like
dude because of you you know there's
there's been a number of years that I've
met so many great people who have
inspired me to say you know what just
keep doing it you're gonna suck it's
okay right I mean we've had those times
I got a good audition I'm like I walk
out going what the hell did I just do my
cousin my cousin
nobody wants a session broke my dick oh
my god then we edition together brothers
as cousin alone it was amazing so much
fun going through that oh my god yeah
you know I think they went to with two
guys who were older than us yeah so on
but the fact that I like me and I'm
surprised I haven't worked with you know
you know you're it was so much fun and I
think they had no idea of how far we
could take these characters which which
which after that I was like thinking
wait how come I've never done anything
with Felipe you know think you know I
blame you
give me a development deal and they were
gonna get picked up I need them yeah I
had a development deal last year for ABC
yeah and they're you know they didn't
decide to shoot the pilot but we're
gonna go with Fox next year and we had
like we had it all man but it's okay
ma'am apology they got turned down to
Johnson Gabriel it just happens but
those five
shows up for grabs in the tournament up
next we're gonna have 20 so you can't
tell her no forever be cool man that's
right that's right keep standing and I
think you just think stay positive man I
people say what the you're not gonna
give it a hearing everything you did I
earn everything but you couldn't meet
the right people man stay quiet don't
talk [ __ ] ever you have your back oh
yeah I think I know it man if you talk
[ __ ] about somebody make sure the other
person starts talking [ __ ] first
somebody that everybody agrees that we
don't like right back
feel one man fight how you in the mirror
you made like somebody too busy that you
said this guy was mean yeah there was I
don't wanna see mean it was just you
know he's a cool guy accident you know
III gotta say you know William Shatner
well Shatner William said you know
here's a reason why cuz I was flying
from the East Coast back into LA you
know with the guy played Kip Aaron rule
and he was a big fan so I was like you
know there I am you know and he is a
dude and like it is a big Star Trek fan
yeah hardcore
well course you okay so yeah and and and
so we said hide it will immersed in a
sense the yeah we're both actors here's
the camera both action big fan and he
just turned him down dude dissed him
like what could you can't do that to my
homie like really I love Star Trek come
on to trouble with tribbles I love that
so so next you know we get on the plane
right and and you know we're seeing them
the second row and guess who's sitting
next to me Captain Kirk so I'm looking
at Aaron and Aaron's can i calling me
down is like don't say anything I'm like
dude I can't I can't somebody pulls out
oh yeah yeah yeah boy yeah you if you
put me down I don't care if you put my
friend down and bring them down now I'm
gonna say something so I'm like you know
we're getting ready and you know
flight attendants all I excited the fact
that you [ __ ] start tricking a point
dynamite like wow this is so great
something wait a minute okay so uh there
you go
so that strange you know if if we have
the captain's sitting next to us so
who's gonna fly the plane
and then his face has got red like I
like and then Erin's they cracking up he
knows yeah
so I go over to the city because Aaron
is sitting right by the window and I'm
like hey uh say reach out to me look out
the window go hey uh I think there's a
gremlin on the wing and I don't find
that funny
he was Mexican TJ Hooker I just want to
know if his stomachs soft or hard
the harder joy Coco
I think it's both sorry
hopped does his hair come with a zipper
[Laughter]
justjust don't be here's the rule he's
over it rules are don't be mean don't
diss people [ __ ] kid with a back off
sad I know this little mustache is tried
from time travel machine yeah don't be a
fool please please go read mm-hmm you
have played Southwest yeah captain Crewe
that a first-class [ __ ] captain get
off my lawn he probably gets mad because
you guys tell your actors and Star Trek
without much of acting robro like look I
get it maybe he was consolidated
overwhelmed who knows maybe he was
missing yeah
Spock I don't know so but because I've
been in that situation we've all been
there you know at the airport you just
want to be left alone you're high you're
like oh my god I just want to sleep I
get it
you know I understand but that doesn't
mean it's ok to be a jerk that doesn't
mean that you you know you don't be mean
these people can totally move ahead I
love you Expedia commercials so I gotta
take it you know said after the point
dynamite all the actors started to work
we are said to work in different
projects the guy the actor played Kip
he's actually a director he directs a
lot of commercials you know soda jared
has you know we were always working in
the business you know cuz people wonder
the quote so whatever happened to all of
you guys you know what's going on but
we're always so so busy and if I could
for me and there are a lot of actors who
keep playing the same roles but and
that's exactly who they are for me if I
could hide behind all these characters
and cool
hell yeah you know and and Aaron roll
him and his wife is a editor so and he's
been working in commercials non-stop for
years really so you know so we've been
very fortunate all of us we've been very
lucky and fortunate and grateful to what
has happened to us you know and if you
could entertain the audience worldwide
then then when you know it's great
that's what's up dude yeah whatever
happened to laFonda yeah I love him
Sandra she was on a TV show a few TV
shows actually here I'm the old channel
I don't the hotel does that still yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah she was on the TV
show I'm that and she works is as a
character actress and on different shows
and different films yeah how she was a
how many crazy fans ask oh that time all
the time how cool you know spin-off
football in the mountains there was
there was a talk actually of wanting to
make a sequel couple years afterwards
and there was also talked about making a
prequel on how they all got together you
know the fact that you know Jon Heder
Napoleon is hunting for Wolverines and
and kept doing cage fighting
and Pedro crossing you know the Grand
Canyon with them you know having them
get into Preston Idaho
so uncle Rico man winter go in yes how
about the grandma bros you flew off into
a teeny major Reno for you know from a
water world and create a karina she
they're all actors whose exceptional
cast yeah yeah yeah yeah so what it's
like even when it's over any cat came on
board I was like okay what am i doing
you know God all right cool and they
were just so remarkable as the character
that they played with the guy recognized
everywhere and they expect you to talk
that way you don't sound like Paige on
real life yeah well I don't know what
you're talking about
I wrote a book and and in going to
universities and colleges and talking to
the students some universities the first
thing I would say is this university
would never accept me as a student but
here I am teaching you guys about Fiat
er history and then film history and
acting great you you you it's such a
such a surprising thing because when I
start talking to them they're like oh
wow he doesn't really speak like Pedro
[Laughter]
he says what is happening was so people
reach you at social media they can find
me on Instagram you know the it's it's
the real dot you know a friend that I
meet us because there's there's and I
recently started the Instagram yeah
buried in my work whatever like a big
nerd but I finally you know I did a show
with uh with Rob Lowe and Fred
and and Rob's like amen you gotta you
gotta Instagram and like uh no no not
really you you should get one you know
there's uh you know there's a statue of
Napoleon right in the box a lot yeah
here yeah it's gonna t-shirt with you
with your name on it I go oh see front
yes it's not about my says Pedro and
yeah you should you should get it you
know should you know good yeah and like
uh we try to say hey that's coming
standing into the den I won the show but
I'm one of the show's I were a vote for
Felipe shirt
cuz I want people to vote for me to win
votes for me a win but I want to go do a
show in like Allentown Pennsylvania and
I get Allentown yeah I know that face
I'm not a front in the front row so this
old white couple like 62 years old
yeah and they made their own vote for
Felipa t-shirt follow you but that I
made it was so full one of the most
iconic roles ever like nobody never
forget that bro it's big man and every
time I am mexican-american had a row
it's so memorable boy you forget it
because we don't have that many I know
man
even if the guy's not Mexican remember
it haha you know that Mexican dude eli
eli wallach from [ __ ] the good bunny
ugly my dad had me convinced you were
Mexican Spain by Jewish for the Bronx
yeah what'd you play that show rope good
man that's how deep you get into a row
when you get into it yeah yeah yeah
there's some rules that are that are
harder than others you know I last year
I did a play I did a play a very heavy
drama and relationship alright it's yeah
it's it's about this guy's I feel like
weird like to telling you guys it's
about this guy he's totally into this
sister
what so he look like normal you playing
the white rule
he's from melon tonight so uh it was a
very really difficult play you know at
night and I I think my last week I
couldn't I couldn't open myself to to to
to the character or to the other actor
and to director and producer and even
the audience I it was just it was so
intense and I and I I just had to let it
go and and but but that led me to do a
pilot for TNT called monsters of God and
it was a civil war piece my character
was half Hispanic and half Native
American he was half Comanche so and I
had to learn a new language for that and
and the intensity of some world that I
play are can be extreme you know so I
understand like a lot of actors who who
do so much work and so much prep work to
get in and you it is very extremely
important to remember that that you had
to find a way out if not you know you
you you go crazy so yeah I don't have
any so a dress I like so you know I like
wall to be able to play that role and
and he was just amazed like amazing
amazing and you know I remember uh
Ricardo Montalban when he played he did
a played a Japanese character you know
in a film with Marlon Brando and it was
amazing another if an actor can really
immerse himself into the role and played
honestly and truthfully then great then
I am kudos to him great but if it's not
convincing you're kind of like ah not
really no because Brando played punch
will be all right
[Music]
and then Anthony Quinn please see see
the giving it the ending again star pain
oh yeah Anthony Quinn I can I get it you
know I get all right better stops good
no but I know I love Brandon's work game
you know about that Godfather poncho
Network welcome massacred my marina were
so fools you got anything to add no
that's it man just holding on the
character dude thank you very much for
being on the podcast oh yeah could I go
to read audition bro not even I just
read over one hour bro I'm really gonna
Wow me but most of them didn't want me I
sound like Jay London coming next so you
know you did a horrible job thank you
you don't awesome job thank you come
again
was so full Ethan Martinez in the house
I did it
Ramirez apron now as Ethan Esparza you
have your little friend Ramirez network
on YouTube to know do I know I did I I
notice that there's a fan page for you
know Facebook and there is a Twitter
it's me but it's just I really I'm
really trying to get more on on the
social media but but I really I find it
more effective to be able to go to high
schools and talk to students directly if
I go to colleges universities and I talk
to students directly about what's going
on with the world in the film and yeah
and if I could do if I can move people
in such way in an entertaining way with
films then hell yeah dude from TV shows
to movies and if you do something
positive that brings the light to the
planet that's so dark at this very
moment you know then yeah sure was so
full
HBO special this Saturday at 10 o'clock
my HBO special premieres oh hell yeah
hell yeah and I got five billboards by
the way that just in two of them hell
yeah
never had a billboard in my life
furgus its title okay what your mom was
here either this guy used to pee in his
pants oh well so thank you friend for
being a guest on the show my pleasure my
pleasure